we have a star
this is this image looks familiar i've
seen it everywhere
it's been doing the rounds quite a lot
it's been on the news so yes this is an
image with the james webb space
telescope
pointing at a star making a star of a
star so this is a calibration image they
really are at the point really of just
making sure that the telescope's all
focused and that everything's lined up
and that they can actually get
everything to work i have struggled hard
to think of anything interesting to say
about this style i've been looking in
the literature to see what there is
it's a remarkably non-descript star i
suspect it was chosen probably because
it's fairly boring right it's not you
know it's not so bright that it would uh
sort of blind the telescope it's not so
faint that they wouldn't actually be
able to use it to focus the telescope
with it's got no companions so you can
get a nice sharp image of an individual
style is it got a cool name no it's got
a telephone number
it's two mess [ __ ] j and then a whole
bunch of numbers i'm afraid so it's a
sufficiently non-descript star it
doesn't have any kind of name it's too
faint to have a you know a historic name
uh it's much fainter than anything you
can see with the naked eye
so it's yes not a very exciting star i'm
afraid it's about 2 000 light years away
traveling towards us at a modest speed
of 50 kilometers per second so you know
2000 light years away it's kind of a
modest distance it's not very far it's
not very near it's traveling towards us
is about 50 kilometers per second which
is you know not very slow not very fast
uh it's a bit brighter than the sun
intrinsically um so it's probably not i
don't think it's a main sequence star i
think it's probably off towards the
giant branch so it's a slightly more
giant star than the sun is uh it's i
think it's about
5000 degrees something like that in
terms of its temperature so a little bit
cooler than the sun which means you'll
be a little bit redder than the sun it
really is a remarkably nondescript star
it's had its moment of glory now and now
it'll fade back into obscurity i did
notice it now has its own wikipedia page
but the only thing the wikipedia page
says is that it was used for calibrating
the james webb space telescope so i
think that's probably the you know the
highest point it's going to reach in
terms of its stardom as a star
in some sense this is the culmination
right this is this is a success but it's
been quite a lengthy process you
remember the james webb space telescope
launched back
several months ago now made its way out
to its orbit everything worked extremely
well everything's gone incredibly well
in terms of for example the launch was
so good that they actually didn't have
to do much by way of kind of mid course
correction as it was going to its orbit
which means they now have more fuel left
over than they thought they'd have which
has effectively doubled the lifetime
they think it's going to have
so it's now should be out there taking
doing astronomy for about the next 20
years so all good news but obviously
then having got it there the next thing
they needed to do was set up the
telescope just as you predicted it's all
gone to plan absolutely i was absolutely
confident it was all going to go fine
and yeah nothing could possibly go wrong
i mean you know they're not at the end
of the process i think probably
the things that are most likely to go
wrong have now been passed but that's
not to say that there aren't still
things where things could go astray but
it is it's today it's all been
incredibly good news and as i say
hopefully they're kind of past the most
difficult stages now okay calibration so
the first thing you do
is you pick a star and you just take a
picture with your telescope
and what you find the foot when you
first take your picture is something
that looks more or less like this and of
course here the problem is so actually
there is only one star in this image
although it looks like there are many
stars that's because there are 18
separate mirrors and of course they're
all pointed in slightly different
directions which means that the the
where the image appears is slightly
different for each of the 18
mirrors that they've got there and so
you end up first of all with this you
know complete mess of the stars all over
the place
and of course the first thing you have
to do is you don't actually even know
which mirror corresponds to which image
here so the first thing you do is you
wiggle each mirror a little bit in turn
and see which image moves
and so once you've done that you can
then kind of identify
which of those images corresponds to
which mirror so that kind of gives you
your first sort of calibration point of
telling you you know what's going on
what's producing what professor what
does the word wing mean on that so i
think that's these are the ones remember
that the the telescope kind of unfolded
and i think wings are the ones that the
mirror is on the edges of the bits that
kind of fold it out and i think so this
yeah because there's three on each side
and so i suspect that these are the two
two wings worth of mirrors that have
folded out
so once you've figured out what's what
then the next sort of sensible thing to
do is you rearrange them
and so this is just basically again
moving the mirrors around so they've got
little pistons behind them so they can
redirect the mirrors they can move them
in and out to focus but they can also
move them around to change their
orientation relative to one another so
you were just to rearrange them in a
much more rational pattern so that you
know which mirrors which and what's
where without having to keep referring
to some kind of random pattern of things
so that's the the alignment that they
did of just kind of getting the all the
mirrors in individual individually in
the right places and you can just see
looking at them you know some of them
are relatively close to being in focus
and some of them look completely
horrible at this point
and so the next thing you need to do
then is focus each of these individually
and there are lots of tricks that they
could play to do the focusing um for
example so there's the secondary mirror
which is the bit that so the light comes
to the primary mirror out to the
secondary mirror back to the the
instruments at the back you can move the
secondary mirror which sort of changes
the focus of the whole telescope and by
changing the focus of the telescope in
that kind of controlled way and seeing
how those images change you can figure
out how far out of focus the individual
mirrors are what direction you need to
move them in to bring them into focus so
the next stage of the process was each
of those 18 mirrors needed to be brought
into focus which is
this step here where everything is now
much sharper than it was before
everything is nicely in focus of course
at this point you've still got all your
mirrors pointed in slightly different
directions which is why you have this
sort of array of images rather than one
image so the next thing you want to do
is point all the mirrors in exactly the
same direction which will bring all
those image images together
which is what we get to with this point
here which looks kind of like the final
point that we were trying to get to but
it isn't quite and the reason what still
hasn't been done
is all that's happened here is so each
of those little segments is acting like
a little you know one and a bit meter
telescope rather than a single six and a
half meter telescope and when you bring
them all together you just end up you
end up with the same amount of light
that you get from your full six and a
half meter telescope but the quality of
the images is just the quality of the
image that you get from a one meter
telescope rather than a six meter
telescope and so the sharpness of the
images is being driven by those
individual mirrors you've just added the
light together so you just combined
everything together to produce a single
you know a brighter image because it's
got all the light there but the
sharpness of the image is still being
limited by the fact that it's only the
single mirrors that you're seeing that
are producing the images
so the final stage of the process is a
thing called phasing the mirror which is
that you need to make it instead of a
whole bunch of effectively separate
telescopes all pointing in more or less
the same direction you need it to be
behaving as if it were a single mirror
six and a half meters across which means
you need to align all of those mirrors
perfectly to within a fraction of a
wavelength of light and so and once
you've done that then the light from one
side of the mirror and the light from
the other side combines in this coherent
fashion which means that the whole thing
acts as if it were a single mirror and
again there are there are sort of tricks
calibration tricks that are built into
the telescope so for example within the
instrument that's being used to do the
focus there is a way to effectively put
the telescope out of focus but in a very
controlled way so before when we were
doing that course thing as i say you
just basically move the secondary mirror
in and out but within the instrument
itself there are actually are kind of
optical components that allow you to put
the telescope out of focus in a very
controlled way
and you can use how the images change
when you change the focus in that very
controlled way to figure out exactly how
much you need to move the individual
components around to get them all to
behave like this single mirror but and
obviously these pistons aren't like you
know the holes in my belt where you've
got four or five options you can really
fine grain it it really is very very
finely adjusted because you are
literally moving the things by less than
you know less than a single much less
than a single wavelength of light so
that brings us back to this which is
when that final stage of the process has
been done the mirrors have all been
phased in this way so that actually the
the sharpness of the image here is the
sharpness you get from a six and a half
meter telescope not from a 1.3 meter
telescope and indeed they measured the
sharpness of the image and it's spot on
in fact it's i think it's slightly
exceeded the expectations as to how well
they thought they'd be able to do this
whole process professor anyone that
looks at that image one of the first
things they're going to comment on are
those huge spikes coming off we've
talked we've done a video many years ago
about diffraction spikes but can you
explain why there are those spikes
coming off the star that's not part of
the star is it no the star really is
point-like at least of the the image
quality that we can get with a with a
telescope like jwst but all the bits you
see sticking out here are artifacts
associated with the telescope
the the big ones you see that sort of
six-pointed star
is to do with the hexagonal symmetry of
the telescope and effectively it's
effectively a hexagonal mirror rather
than a round mirror and so the the sharp
spikes you see sticking out are
artifacts associated with those straight
edges that six-fold symmetry of a
hexagon so that's those ones and then
the other bit that you can see sticking
out the middle here
that's an additional diffraction feature
and that's associated with the fact that
there's this secondary mirror which is
held up by a tripod of legs
and so those there's a sort of shadow
from those three legs that are also cast
on the mirror which have their own
diffraction effects and this is an
artifact that arises from that
diffraction why is this not a problem
are we not going to get these god-awful
spikes on all our lovely images of the
early part of the universe we absolutely
are and in fact so as you can see
there's not only this star here but
there are many other objects in this
field and actually each of those has
these features as well
but you can't see them and the reason
you can't see them is or perhaps
conversely the only reason why you see
them on this star here is this is a
really bright star from jwst's point of
view you know they're very rarely going
to observe anything as bright as this so
these spikes are a tiny fraction of the
total light in the middle the light in
the middle here is completely saturated
and so in terms of you know how big an
effect it is relative to the star itself
it's a tiny thing and so when you start
looking at fainter objects you know
there are even fainter spikes sticking
out from them but you'll never see them
the cool thing about this image there
really is not the star despite your best
attempts to make me get excited about
this star the cool stuff in this image
is that even though they weren't trying
there are dozens and dozens of galaxies
here so i think was about half an hour
exposure so it's quite a short exposure
from what they're going to be doing with
jwst and yet even at that point they're
seeing lots and lots of galaxies in at a
level of detail that i don't think we've
really seen before um without even
trying and so there's lots of excitement
about the fact that there are many many
galaxies here nasa are being quite
careful not to release the raw data here
because they know perfectly well if they
release the raw data there will be many
astronomers out there who'd start trying
to do astronomy with it and they really
want to get their telescope nicely
calibrated before these people start
actually trying to do science with it so
you can find many jpeg copies of this
image but you won't find you know the
raw astronomical data anywhere i'm
getting more and more you know i'm
allowing myself to be excited you know
previously you're kind of holding
yourself back because you've always got
in the back of your mind that there
might be this enormous disappointment
waiting around the corner i think the
chances of that disappointment they're
not gone but they're now receding
so yeah i'm sort of getting more excited
plus when you know when you start seeing
images like that where when the
telescope isn't even trying
it's finding all these beautiful little
galaxies
um
i think that it's a sort of taster of
what's to come and what for our star is
this the last time we'll ever talk about
this star
i suspect so yes it'll fade back into
obscurity now because there really isn't
anything very exciting to say about this
star other than the fact that it was the
star that was used to prove that the
jwst was aligned correctly
i'm going to make it my life mission
to find something
to give that star more glory
at this point if you think about what
the pools of gravity is doing the sun is
pulling you that way the earth is
pulling you that way so both of them are
tugging you in the same direction so the
net pull on a satellite here is stronger
than just the pull of the sun